this is a production of Cornell
University
I wanted to understand how to deliver
resistance I have a master's in plan and
improvement because I wanted to be able
to provide to the farmers good varieties
that were resistant but I could not
accomplish that if I didn't understand
plant pathology I needed to understand
the pattern inside so that was my idea
get a master implant pre-paid a PhD in
Plant Pathology bring it together so you
can deliver the best so that's how my
career started working with of Puerto
Rico in Nebraska and then when I started
working with the USDA I couldn't pick a
better system was working on crown roast
of oats but they had to do genetics and
oats I needed to find resistance it's if
some of you have worker knows you know
how difficult it's the work on oh it's
so ed there was not a lot of resources
so that was a good training and then
from there I went on into working on
stammers of wheat and that's the story
that i'm going to tell your little bit
about today i wanted to start on their
this premise and this is why what we do
what we do plan protection in general
and the perfection of plants fine
diseases and to pets is essential for
food security in a lot of times we don't
see it that way or the media doesn't
portray that way order in general we
have done research for so many years
trying to increase productivity in the
20th century that's what we focus on how
we're going to feed the world that's how
we're going to produce more but a lot of
times we forget that we're already
producing quite a bit but we're losing a
lot to pathogens and passed in the field
after harvest in the only quantity but
also in quality so if we can try to
retain sort of that loss with maybe that
the job is not so tough going
for work and we know that feed in the
world is not real news this has been
portrayed in the 60s we knew that there
was a large population that we needed to
feed in the future but now we're facing
having to produce more food than ever
before we need to increase our
production by seventy percent to be able
to feed nine billion people by 2050 so
that's the challenge right there so we
need to take a multi-faceted approach we
cannot only look at it from the
production side but also in the
protection of our yields and a lot of
times I've timed that
when we think about food security to
look at the components we need to look
at first
we need to look at production it's
availabilities what we're looking at
production and also how we storage how
we reserved we need to look also into
how we can afford it how can we access
that food so that would be physically
like in the market be able to work you
know market girls are having the money
to buy to be able to afford it so that
our accessibility to it but also it's
also how we utilize it so we talking
about nutrition but also we're talking
about safety we know we know about
toxins we know about us harvest so we
need to talk about how to utilize the
better a balanced diet so food security
requires different components and we
need to take that into account with your
research so how we fix it up in this big
picture so most of you are probably
aware that we need a lot of weak the
world is a lot of weed but we provide
twenty to thirty percent of the proteins
in the world and in many parts of the
world it also accounts for up to a third
of the calories that are consumed in a
daily basis so he's extremely important
you know for us here in the US we may be
a piece of bread he may be cookies in
the decade but in many parts of the
world it is what you get every day it is
what is the base of your or your diet so
we need to take that into consideration
we talk about food security he has to be
balance the weight is not that the only
code that we need to pray we need to
protect our ladies we need to protect
many other sources of
quickly is essential in that balanced
diet and I don't think I need to explain
them whether we know about stem rose we
know what happened in the u.s. we know
about barbarian education that started
an IV step 1917 and over 8 million of
bushes of farmers were eliminated
eradicated from the US and he was in an
easy path but it was necessary and this
is a perfect example how can human can
change the situation this was in a very
radical way we changed the entire
population of a pathogen by removing the
sexual reproduction in many parts of the
work out the in the US and but there
still are very salutary we know that in
the Pacific drivers we have a population
and we are aware and we have seen the
devastation that could cause for example
in a specific year in a specific
location for example on barley we know
there are still races of Decembrist
fabric coming out of that sexual
population that has affected barley
production recently in the US and even
after the barbarian education they were
still epidemic so that the solution was
not it was not complete but he helped a
lot because now we're going from seeing
you know dozens of racist every year to
see more or less one race every year he
tell us that the dominant race in the US
so that's what we can do for example if
we intervene but that's not possible
everywhere in the world it is a solution
that it was okay to do and he was able
to manage the diseases of it any
controller we manage it for in a
particular location but it's not an
approach
they were white so we thought we put it
to rest after the fifties we didn't see
major epidemics but then in 1998 William
gory in Uganda identified the first year
postures of ug99 the new the new race of
the stem rust pathogen that it was not
supposed to be that these varieties were
resistant have been resistant for a long
time so he knew something wasn't right
in after verification by with other
laboratories because there was only a
few laboratories that can do the race
analysis that was necessary to confirm
the violence of this pathogen then it
was confirmed that yes it was a new race
of stem rust and it had be released on
not only as a 31 that it was a
instrumental on the development of
variety for the world but he was also
very length on many other teens aware
deploy around a hunt the world so the
news is starting to get out the tread
was there and it got the attention of
the media he got the attention of
sponsors investors like the villa
melinda gates foundation in the UK
department for international development
and we then was decided to build a
coalition of scientists that could go
forward and manage this thread so in the
meantime I was like the USDA and I'd a
working on oats in thanks to the
delivery of the durable roster
sustaining we project there was an
opportunity for a postdoc position at
Ida in Idaho to work on stammers and I
was
I wanted to be part of the team so I
decided to take the test and to start to
grow up and start working in a new
disease and shortly after I went to
Kenya and it's i evaluated materials and
we look at that erases the hood harbor
near resistance two huge 99 and it was
during that period of time then I was
offered the opportunity to go with the
North Dakota so after one year of being
working on on the stammerer thing is
starting to collaborate with the
international community then I had a new
test that he was to develop my own
research program at North Dakota State
University to tackle the same problem
they were concerned about ug99 and so
they got a position that like one of
those was that you don't see any more
demand it wasn't working rust that was
the mandate so how could I not take take
the chance and say hey let's see what we
can do and see now with the network of
people that I have not only in the US
but across the world this peak from that
community and trying to help so I
develop my program then identity at NAB
su and you know they needed it because
we in North Dakota is almost a two
billion dollar industry and this is
probably under estimating how we affect
other areas not only of Agriculture for
the economy in general of the state and
based on the historical evidence they
needed to be worried because yes they
didn't have epidemics of ephemeris in
the near past because we have been able
to manage the different races that we
been able to put varieties that have
resistance but they had the environment
for the disease development even after
they eradication of the barbarous North
Dakota saw fifty-six percent yield
losses in 1935 so they knew that in this
huge 99 or any other races that were
asked Faeryland got to that us North
Dakota whoopee it can make trouble so
you made a lot of sense to to develop a
program to tackle these problems so from
the work that i started at the USDA they
can find the race of the Hat resistance
then I was able to to start my project
in North Dakota that it was to use these
favorite memories as one is from Iran
one of the top and half was really good
resistance two companion and then this
older Montenegro land race that has also
good resistance over time so this was
the first project that I started
developing with my first PhD student in
northern girl and so Jason was able to
map this persistent where they divide
that in with that they Magnus was
confirmed by Bungie so it seems like a
good party personalized packaging and
try to determine if this
EOG or against an underutilized so we
can start incorporating a product the
resistant base for power varieties so
after a couple of years and a lot of
investment into developing poppy
populations development new markets that
at that point we're not totally
accessible because this one with that is
Nick chicks were coming out for week so
we were able to not only find a
chromophore hole location of these teens
but also this gene would also map it to
a high density map that were also
identified good genetic markers that can
be used to improve rest is necessary to
utilize it in her eyes in the meantime
we were able to more resources for
coming into we now we were able to
identify some potential genes that can
be done in the region and expertly
during the actual team of interest there
are M DSLR type so at this moment we are
still trying to figure out because for
those of you that have not worked on
your hexaploid grub if you know it's
it's straightforward yeah we have
puppies can you go did we should be able
to go in and identify this gene and then
it's not the cage
so many repetitive units and you have
duplications of the genes so every time
you time to Melvin in the BG know then
you find it again in the BG know when
you're like ok so what I'm dealing with
so I've been really grew a growing
experience of learning experience for me
and for my student and so when we were
worrying about trying to clone the gene
because there was a the golden child
with Susan try to clone this gene
giorgia99 you start changing so now
we're we're not dealing with one or two
race we were working out at this moment
with 14 different variants and our break
gene it was affected to some of them but
not to all of them so the work was
enough we needed to find more resistant
so we start working then with addition
and looking for new sources so
persistent so we went forward second
choice that was that Montenegro landrace
that have raised a debt lanre seemed
really really good we tested again 20
races North American races in the
variants that we had accessible from the
East Africa lineage and it was resistant
to all of them so we said this is the
one who go after it and then we start
doing a mapping and what we found one is
that it was not normally distributed
when we look at the population so we
were like okay this is not looking good
it's not one gene is multiple genes that
we're dealing with now we saw that there
was france-presse it's arrogance and
when we start doing the mapping we have
lots of genes or are these cutie else in
this background so it emitter really
difficult because some of these genes
for example like s or 12 it's not
effective against ug99 but our gene is
right underneath s12 so or we have
Maddie Paranal the yellow as our job but
there's another day
and because we don't have genome of the
week there's a lot that we don't know
what's happening in that particular
arena so just to show you an example so
we find multiple cutie else in the
promise of the C and D and 67 d in 3b
and it continues so we have around five
different q tal forma DNA inheritance
yes it was not been dealing its
quantitative but it is a great position
so I'm not ready to give up we see it in
the field side by side with our checks
and our line has zero and no thesis is
mostly immune every year so what's going
on we need to get to the bottom and the
bottom of it but it is challenging but I
think that's what we do science we just
want to know why you know how we got
here so it gets us interested
yeah so it is in addition when we look
at the different Phil TL you have an
additive effect so we know we cannot
just bring one of the genes we need to
bring both people to tails or genes into
this packet if we want to have that
level of resistance so for those of you
that do genetics and breeding they you
know what the ties that has that in hand
we need to be able to bring all this
genes together and we're talking about
one trade and breeders have to worry
about how many so so it makes it really
interesting in challenging but I think
it's all worth it because we know what
will happen if we don't do the job so
another project that I was involved more
the pathogens I was working on looking
at the population of puccinia tradition
so not stammers we're now talking about
late for us and this was kind of a
personal a very personal project because
I didn't want to just work on stammers
like everybody was working on stammers
because we were seeing it but like I did
my own little side project that I didn't
give it to my student I wanted to work
on it myself on my spare time so every
time I went to Kenya and Ethiopia I had
to sound that I found I had a permit so
i can bring Christina introducing it to
the states and working with jim palmer
in the usda they were able to look at
the diversity of the packaging and based
on previous report from James work we
knew that there was a unique population
of the symmetry Cena pathogens in in
Ethiopia something that it means never
if we never been observed anywhere else
in the world and we didn't know why so
what we started looking at this isolates
the first thing that we notice is that
they are not Faeryland on the
Rachel said the weeds for classification
so now it's like okay so what do we do
now we put it on the differential set
any doesn't grow on the differential
said so we kind of give it a race number
so early so we don't know what is the
balance complexity of this pathogen but
we know that we see it every year on
during with the tetraploid simple heck
supporter is our greatly this is on the
past week and every week that are also
pet reports in Ethiopia and we found
cinder pockets of populations in North
Africa in the beta Rainier region when
nothing like we saw in Ethiopia so this
is one of the ongoing project kind of
again my side projects just something to
play with where we can still try to
figure out what's going on what is so
unique about with you here we have some
hypotheses in Ethiopia there's a lot of
pet reporter which that has been there
for under severe so this population has
evolved in isolation from other we don't
see this popular this setup was being
grown as a crop parts of the world but
in AZ okay they are up to seven percent
of the crop so there is a unique
population so we will continue working
on it I'm going to mention does this so
in addition to producing others another
leafless pathogen they have never been
given much importance and this is a
coccinea dorian Teresa Toria so again it
only grows on the room and has been
observed in north africa morocco in
calvert spain portugal and it doesn't
have the same alternate hope it has
allowed in your host let's go on to cite
out
this bleep tweet here next to the week
so I was in Morocco face today one of
our collaborators we were looking at
leaf rust and we're in the field and I
just see the week and like happening
here so we know the alternate host for
this other person is present in the
region what is the significance of that
we don't know we don't know is part of
the epidemiology of gravity there we
don't know what what role it fights at
this point but looking back in the
literature there is evidence that each
hydrogen could be a bridge for having
recombination vivid tristina Andoria
there's a potential for it but also we
have a lot of other wild relatives of
wheat in the region that we haven't
looked at yet so our day resolutions of
these other pathogens and that to play a
role of what the violence that we see in
and so there's a lot of questions out
there that have not been answered that
in terms of a brush you know we would
think that by now we have study breath
so much and we will have all the answers
but it's not the case and I like it that
way I like that not only for job
security but also because it's like you
know there is a lot more to do you know
the accelerator tanya h what it tells us
that there's also a lot of potential
solutions out there so we are not aware
because the better we understand the
system the better we can
so this is the result they have
preliminary results of the work where we
see the GOP isolate so you can see here
these are the break with that type
support we isolate their here in here
and then from Kenya you can see actually
it's also programming but then you look
at what is this a race except the one
that they don't grow on the differential
cities are the ones are comic from amer
week and from Durham in there up here on
their own and they are given different
than other your own iPhones that
actually grow on the differential said
is that what we put the V races that are
highly virulent on the leaf rust genes
that are present on common wheat but
they are very very different so what is
the evolution of these isolated I forgot
to be okay while we have an observed of
anywhere else in the world in the world
and what you know is there resistance
there that we have not explored
only to these races but to other races
that not only Jews in Norway / can be
utilized in tech support because the
isolated Roman Durham bro well on the
hex accordingly apparently in the
isolates that are very length of the
hexaploid week I not hearing on the door
so it's a beautiful coevolution study
that I think is worth worth investing on
to determine is there's precision that
we have over dope there's new path and
we can explore so science it was it was
a lot of fun work in Nordic or having my
own research project having my own
greenhouses and the grad students but
there was a larger call for me the
farmers were still the main goal get
into the farmer get it out to the field
making those varieties available so he
was brave mapping those gene he was
great to try to clone the gene but if
that gene stays in a shell it doesn't do
any good you know we had invest all the
time and
money in that research and if it doesn't
make it to the field if it's not
beautiful like how I'm going to utilize
that those genes that are present in
that content agree- I would bring them
together however system that is
effective only furious can be combined
the other resistant than another and
then in it took to the field so we can
feed the world so that's how I ended up
or down because I know that I can count
on a great coalition of scientists a
great community of scientists that was
calling to action by the preneur my
board look in 2005 and during when he
saw the thread of ug99 he knew what
needed to happen in he sounded the alarm
so it was great to know that I was not
alone that there was a group of
scientists at to use the expertise have
developed but also that I can
collaborate with in so i took the role
coming to cornell in a start of working
on building on what was built on the
gravel road for system project from 2008
on and when the drug across the system
project it was to use a multi-faceted
approach to manage spam browser
specifically Eugene
I where they look at understanding the
pathogen looking at the alternate host
new gene discovering that was key part
of the project we're also developing
markers for those things so we can
better utilize them we also look at the
non-polar system to see if there was
anything there that we can utilize again
to try to manage the disease and of
course breeding Pacific we don't do the
breathing aspect again it just stays on
the shelf or stays on journal articles
but it doesn't make it to the field and
then we need a cig multiplication
capacity building with what what a thing
is very unique about this project if
they took into account only the
scientific component with a social
component how do we develop a new
generation of scientists they can take
the job on it for the next decades
because when you generating i came up
there was only a few people in the world
they knew about stem rose they have seen
as stem rose in the new what to do so we
needed to develop this new generation of
scientists and then the world has
changed we know that gender in science
was something that needed to be talked
about I needed to be approached from a
very scientific point of views like we
need to bring together the best of the
best and we need to be very concerned
about leaving people behind the curd
bringing lots of great ideas in should
be respected equally so they took into
this multifaceted approach to really
deal with the problem and I think it was
it was really what attracted me to
position to know that I access and to
this fantastic network of people so this
is the partnership that it was developed
during the gravel road for see study
week project and as you see it's a goal
of partnership in thats words one of the
strengths of this project because you
have experts around the world with
different life experiences with
different background in by grossing
genetics and breeding my pathology
Social Sciences you have all of it you
have laboratory that could take samples
Labrador that were very rudimentary but
they have the passion to do the work
they only needed the training so
building on that is where the new
project that delivery of genetic any
wheat comes about it was launched in
part that's when I joined the team and
right now my responsibilities to manage
the scientific components of this this
project is bringing some leadership and
some help the sciences do what they need
to do be able to provide for that
community give it to communicate between
the different groups so we work together
we don't have competitive efforts in but
we will utilize the resources the best
that we can and also come up with new
ideas how you know if I talk to somebody
in one laboratory and see that they
should connect one on
I can bring those collaborations but at
the same time having a background in
Ross of all this inner health so this is
how the project looks with it started in
2008 is the first phase of the drummer
brushes anyway second phase and now it's
where we are with eg you don't live in
these are the main objective of the
projects that is to modernize reading
programs cement and national programs in
India and South Asia it also we're
looking at surveillance we're looking at
how the populace change move and we
predicted can we put additional models
out there not only that we can say oh
yeah this is a new race or the races
show up last year was this place know
what you want to do it looking back or
if you wanted to look forward can we
predict where we're going to see the
next epidemic can we determine what
races are the best chances of moving
into a different location that we're
looking at and we're going to continue
human capacity building this is the
approach that we're taking similar as
before putting more effort into
the surveillance during the where you
see that phenotyping platform that is
where we use our field plots in Kenya
and Ethiopia to be able to screen as
many materials from around the world so
we can move forward faster but also
we're using new technologies because
we're looking at rust we are looking at
how can we deliver a better time how we
some resistance one trade but we need to
look at deal with quality we need to
look at climate is changing so now we
have to grow more weight in less space
on their less resources can we find
better drought older eat torrent wheat
varieties can we make that part of the
packet so that's what we're working with
our team's a semi and national programs
around the world to try to identify the
only persistent for us which is a story
of another area that we're looking at
we're also looking at
so as I mentioned we were expanding our
surveillance when the project is
starting 2008 it were just a couple of
laboratories that can handle race
identification and only few groups were
sharing the on the risks that they were
observing how we have many countries
collaborating and bringing gala every
year so we could track the package and
better and also predict where we may
observe in the next season we are
continuing overbreeding effort then
expanding on the effort that we're
developing for we're going to bring new
technology like the lunatic selection
hydrography of typing so these spirits
are using your technology the best of
the best that that is out there to
develop new new systems to do the work
better more efficient to delivered
américain to increase the rate of
genetic
because the phenotype in fight up a part
very large feel lots in different parts
of the world that are hot spots for a
specific traits or legging the case of
rust it was Kenya Ethiopia no worries in
yoga for septoria but also swimming is
looking into fighting additional
platforms that they can utilize for
drought for example in Mexico right now
they're using changing the planet it's
fine to be able to get drought and heat
test for poor tolerance in drought we're
going to continue our advocacy and this
is something that it goes over so many
times the importance of communicating
the science not only through the media
the public for policymakers
understanding the value of regaining
science-based information powder to
remove the misinformation in the fear
that the public and the media and even
over scientists have about what what's
happening in our part of the world
in case of technology in general radiant
hospice waiting for you to read 30
should we do it in a friendly so
advocacies is key not only for
communicating vessels what also attract
additional funding we go I'm sure you're
all aware how difficult is to find
funding for public goods they said it to
continue that working requires
communication and
we're going to continue our talent I'd
like with doing training of your
computer scientists this will be sure
and come for trainings include so week
training or sending somebody for a PhD
abroad and also try to maintain the
knowledge in the country we don't want
to deploy the countries of their first
more sparse London for body-colored life
in that community
country so try to encourage that
advocating for those it rewarding those
mentors that make for females and
minorities into a great job of
recognizing that everybody should have a
place in science and computer science
we're going to do that at management we
know we're talking about Big Data we're
talking about having gross other need to
feel how are we going to process the
data you know now before the bottleneck
was like I cannot walk fast enough I
don't have that many hours in the day
for like my day and now we can collect
today I was like what do we do once we
get the data it so we know that there's
a bottleneck there so we're looking
better ways to manage the data and also
how to share it we are big on open
access and science needs to be fully
operative that you cannot work in
isolation a word of the components of
our project is that every publication
that is all the power projects going to
be
supporters
we're going to do a small part on seed
production in all because of the need
after the earthquake we know that there
is a really big
we can use this as an opportunity to
learn how to develop a small seat system
that could be utilized that I found
well
in the large calls from our headquarters
here at Cornell because we know that we
are very well placed to and respected in
the world to do a great job bringing
science and scientists and public
together there's a lot of trouble
University from the part of the public
but also from from our investors so
they're very old place to collaborate
with others and again with all this they
get to the farmer and pick it up
that I'm back on my defense I would be
at that I Noah so when we talk about
variability of persistent we all they
talk about overtime but also over
Anchorage's so the rubber brush has been
something difficult to define just
because you can only really look like
when you look back it's like how long it
lasted where was established but we know
that there is some key components that
seem to be for relating with her ability
so we're talking about not pretty high
selection pressure on the pattern so the
patterning doesn't evolve as so for
example using like slow rocks engine
seemed to be associated with durability
song not at all we're in some places in
SD
there is some correlation there but we
know that some genes that have lasted
for a long time like a HR 31 what's that
a progression from a different spaces
too weak so for some key component that
we don't understand clearly yet but
there's also some short dangerous when
we start swapping James you know are we
going or not assistant more easier to a
wall so that happening now and go into
other areas not in the past and have
enough seen that necessarily we are rust
but we know that could be a champion but
in terms of durability we're trying to
find ways to stack more genes so when we
took a look at the regulated like if we
put three to five genes together how we
talking about that the pathogen needs to
mutate four or five times to be able to
overcome the resistance in that
particular variety but if we reduce the
amount of be not only a path
Oh on this plant enough we are reducing
the inoculum that is there a mutation
rate is there but the chances of you
know 1 billion sport which is still
building spores maybe we do so i think
the durability has to be look from the
furnace from the whole cyber also quite
is doing on the pathogens I like an
answer suppression
more people are not Billy Corgan
I know we're always excited when viewing
a pipeline so there is a couple of
things on that surveillance aspect so
the surveillance it sound playing more
but also have better sources in the
genotypic side of things so can we
identify markers that would tell us that
usually 99 or is not ordinary night
great so now we have that in place that
Alice can tell us the group we are not
we will not be able to develop raises
specific markers yet but we can tell
that if you won't trust in you so that
is part that it gets incorporated as
soon as samples are collected they're
saying to soda or to Denmark and they
can be evaluated that way which hope
that we can do more of that in get
faster responses so we know what we're
dealing with we are also using more
technology so the farmer or the
researchers in the field and identify is
that establishes asleep roses yellow
rust can upload it can tell you the
coordinates and if we see that it's a
hotspot and we've been de modeling that
we have in place can we say you need to
go and spread you know in the next
region because based on over
pattern and weather and the information
that we have you can you are next so
that's what we're doing with program is
trying to develop an early warning
system that can be incorporated so we
have the brain connected
actually used as Barbara berries are
used as a traditional food
so is anything
fire that's something to be explored yet
you know after the initial confirmation
of huge 99 and yet we haven't seen you
phrases coming out so it can be many
reasons whether you know over this is
triangle so I think explain that that's
all I how are we going this is triangle
goes this way so we don't so we don't
know why that is what we have
those like that very often when the
first let's look at the country
situation imperium in yoga in many areas
in Africa we planted all the time there
is one season after another after
another so we know there is a great
bridge so once you're harvesting one the
other one is already so the trust can
always survive huge hairy Larry per se
which is a a combination of appearance
in one of the key elements was hard
dirty water we know that in fact
everyone has been deployed around the
world many arise so selection pressure
was there we don't know you know the
first evidence of Virgina enemies Africa
I'm around us
writers he seems that it was there
before we are very very low frequency so
you know we got probably selected for it
but the challenge is that there's always
inoculum there's always a house in the
area so we're seeing over the ovarian in
the region because the person
oh so if the hue 99 has been picked up a
Barbary so there's bears in one of those
pieces can is a bicycle around you know
the difference if I don't think have
been confirm that the particular race is
on the barber so we know the barbarism
in the region we don't know all the role
that the Barbary may play because in a
high altitude what is that fella
dangerous efficient use of sealing sex
versus the field
so one of the this is the beautiful
thing working with people then know the
system I have no pathology I normally
work with readers there's a little bit
different or so we have the plane a look
when you have the right questions the
standings has for the wii stem rust
works really well for most of our whole
stages jeans so if genes that are
affected by the ceiling so far are
infected on the adult last stage but
there's genes that are in need of
oakland stage that are not evident at
the ceiling say so we those we cannot
the type at the ceiling stage because a
class looks acceptable the ones you
the field then you have your field
persistence in so we use both these the
seedling test to detect all stage
resistant genes that are normally record
specific and then we work with the adult
plant genes that are some of the slope
Russell now is talking before there tend
to be not racist specific there have a
broad a spectrum of persistence and so
then we look at the latency period so
both of them need to be using
combination but the feeling that is
really helpful for numbers it allow us
to eliminate a lot of materials but
definitely so much ears that are
susceptible the ceiling station will be
resistant of the above flood stage
questions for many of our students are
close to ochsner
that created so the pressure case about
the technologies that we're using like
some of the phenotyping and the genome
mapping is expected to be spread across
every laboratory of their specific
centers know we have centers that are
are doing that the research in we have
for sample genotyping laboratory that
are accessible so people can send their
samples in so we support some of the
USDA laboratories or a laboratory
network and it kind of that kind of the
genotyping for us and we are offering
the opportunity of training for junior
scientists because many countries want
to modernize it I recovery Yoga is one
of those countries that is really
looking forward to modernizing the
agriculture and so they want to like a
rat biology experience so we were
operated training so the opportunity is
there for them they're well trying to go
in the our collaborators
and sell a seminar and varicella says we
would like closer ties with the
pathologist here ourselves has offered
to have meetings with anybody
just the center
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu